dreams are the seeds of action we'd all
do well to remember that a single-handed
race around the world have already sent
in my entry form he's erased alone on a
boat in nine months you're either drunk
or man well we should have another drink
so that we can rule out matters may I
point out he don't have a boat capable
in such a voyage we're gonna build one
have you ever done anything like that
before that's the point if I can do it
then so can the bloke who stares at the
horizon I'm putting in the money what
are you putting in everything else I
thought myself into thinking we were
just building a boat I didn't think I'd
actually have to watch you sail away
that's what boats do promise me you'll
come home any sane man would want to
pull out of such an endeavor leave your
doubts with us here on the show take
your dreams out to sea a great deal of
pressure falls on the man alone on the
boat the sea shows no mercy where the
leaders 3,000 miles and if I go on my
chances of survival would be 50/50
if I came back I face certain right
I can't go on and I can't go home so
where else is there
I'm here what if I tell them my yeah
[Music]
this week Dahle Kroger has been posting
some remarkable speed what do I do now I
thought I could play the game better
Donald Crowhurst wanted to be famous now
he's about to me
we are landing this we put pressure on
the mind
not always connected no matter how far
apart me now tomorrow and every day
often my children will still meet their
father and I will still need my husband
life must be lived so the question
becomes what can you do
give it all meaning
you
you